[Musique]
avec Wellen frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse Hélène la première visite demain
du chancelier allemand en Chine la
Scholl c'est un déplacement décrié par
une partie de ses partenaires européens
du côté de Pékin en tout cas le
gouvernement est tout à fait disposé à
réserver le meilleur accueil à olafolls
de Global Times le quotidien officiel
chinois promet je cite que cette visite
va injecter de la stabilité de l'énergie
aux relations sino-allemande et il
assure que les inquiétudes sur la
dépendance de l'Allemagne vis-à-vis de
la Chine auront un impact limité tant
que le gouvernement allemand s'en
tiendra une position pragmatique
concernant ses propres intérêts ces
inquiétudes sont en tout cas suffisantes
pour que le chancelier allemand est
décidé d'écrire lui-même cette tribune
dans Le fronter algueminaut will
justifie se déplacement par son
pragmatisme précisément la Chine est
restera un partenaire important d'après
le chancelier la pandémie et la guerre
en Ukraine avec ses graves conséquences
aurait rendu impossible le statu quoique
je le cite vis-à-vis de la Chine rendant
ainsi d'une certaine façon obligatoire
ce déplacement à Pékin une visite pour
s'adapter aux nouvelles ordre mondial
l'argument la sceptique des économistes
oui le quotidien britannique souligne
que la scholls et le premier dirigeant
occidental à se rendre à Pékin depuis le
début de la pandémie et il rapporte que
le président français Emmanuel Macron
aurait souhaité voyager avec lui mais de
préférence pas juste après que le
dirigeant suprême chinois je cite chez
Jean Ping s'est fait élire président à
vie en France du coup à la pilule passe
passe particulièrement mal mais que va
donc faire le chancelier allemand dans
cette galère chinoise que veut-il
obtenir à Pékin face à un autre toujours
plus autocratique nationaliste et
intraitable sur la question
louanaise interroge le site d'info
Mediapart qui voit le chancelier
allemand courir le risque d'être
cantonné dans un rôle de représentant de
commerce dans la presse également Hélène
aujourd'hui cette enquête du monde en
partenariat avec un réseau international
de journalistes d'investigation sur les
agissements du groupe paramilitaire
russe Wagner dirigé par un proche de
Vladimir poutineau Soudan
à des documents entre la Russie et le
Soudan montrant je cite un haut niveau
de collusion entre les mercenaires
russes et une partie du pouvoir
soudanais l'objectif étant de profiter
des ressources en or du pays troisième
producteur d'Afrique sont reversés aucun
pourcentage soudain comme l'exige
pourtant la loi en échange la Russie via
le groupe Wagner fournirait aux
autorités soudanaises du matériel de
maintien de l'ordre et des hommes pour
la formation de ces soldats
pardon les travailleurs pardon j'ai
perdu le fil Hélène voilà un mot à
présent du débat en France voilà sur le
nouveau projet de loi asile et
immigration qui sera examinée au début
de l'année prochaine dans un entretien
au Monde toujours le ministre du Travail
Olivier du sceau et celui de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin annonce vouloir créer
dans un souci d'équilibre je les cite un
titre de séjour métier en tension pour
les travailleurs sans papiers déjà
présents sur le territoire français et
mettre en place des mesures pour
améliorer les reconduites à la frontière
des clandestins un texte que Gérald
Darmanin a résumé j'en perds mon latin
en ces termes être méchant avec les
méchants et gentils avec les gentils la
formule laisse assez sceptique Le Figaro
qui regrette que le gouvernement ne
fasse selon lui aucun lien existentiel
entre immigration et délinquance en
l'accusant de kakouillage organisé sur
cette question de l'immigration et pas
très convaincu non plus libération le
journal accuse le gouvernement de jouer
au jeu dangereux des bons et des
mauvaises immigrés en évoquant je cite
toujours une tentative hasardeuse pour
endiguer la montée du rassemblement
national les travailleurs immigrés à
Hélène dont plusieurs ONG ont dénoncé
les conditions de travail au Qatar
notamment sur les chantiers du Mondial
de foot qui commence dans quoi une
petite moindre un jour en effet à moins
de 20 jours du coup d'envoi de cette
compétition le Monde rapporte que le
gouvernement Cathary a rejeté les appels
à créer un fond d'indemnisation pour les
migrants tués ou blessés sur les
chantiers de construction du mondiale le
journal c'est un entretien publié hier
dans lequel le ministre du Travail du
Qatar dénonce je le cite un coût de
communication de la part des ONG qui
viennent en aide aux travailleurs
étrangers ce Mondial 2022 ne cessent des
idées déciderment pas de créer le
malaise comme en témoigne cette une de
l'humanité
qui dénonce le grand braquage du sport
par le Qatar en particulier et les pays
du Golfe en général on se quitte pas là
dessus Hélène si je vous demande Pauline
si vous savez pourquoi les canetons
nagent que le le derrière la maman canne
saurait vous me répondre je ne sais pas
Hélène mais en tout cas c'est très
sérieuse question a été soulevée par des
chercheurs chinois et britanniques et
ils ont finalement trouvé la réponse
contrairement à ce que vous imaginez
peut-être ce n'est pas pour que la force
de résistance de l'air soit concentré
sur la maman canne profitant aussi
profitant ainsi au travail des canetons
non les chercheurs montré qu'en réalité
le sillage créé par la maman Ken stimule
les talents de surfeur des canetons qui
apprennent ainsi à se positionner de
manière optimale sur ses vagues pour
être tirés en avant c'est tellement
efficace que les canetons de tête n'ont
presque jamais besoin de PA pour avancer
et que même si les petits derniers sont
légèrement désavantagés les vagues du
sillage sont suffisamment hautes pour
que toutes les couvées puissent en
profiter parfaitement mais est-ce que ce
serait pas une très belle métaphore de
la maternité Hélène cette démonstration
scientifique probablement merci beaucoup
allez à tout à l'heure dans Paris